la veille christophe viewing tonight
gelé plusieurs assurances est content de
vous avoir
ça aurait pu changer de robe je traduis
bien vous étiez donc marié on va en
parler avec donald trump le fameux homme
d'affaires américain vous êtes désormais
divorcés massimo j'ai dit qu'il était
organisateur d'événements organisateurs
de fêtes
mais il est aussi marieur il présente
des gens souvent et c'est massimo qui
vous a présenté votre jeu pas grandir
votre boyfriend actuelle oui italien il
les a vus ingénieurs
il prend des coups et les masses tout ce
que n'est pas massimo d'ailleurs sympa
ah oui mais chez moi nous parlait
massimo nous parle de la cruauté dans la
jet set
non mais tous les deux une personnalité
absolument génial et tous les deux c'est
les meilleurs hommes de la terre non il
donnera mittal est un ami d'enfance et
lui
oui je connais non j'ai qu'on ait laissé
sa mère et mange tes amis des amis
maman ne rêve pas parce que vous dites
ma vie est plus agité que le plus agité
des romande aventure et c'est vrai c'est
vrai que la ville ivana trump est une
vie exceptionnelle
donc on va raconter un petit peu votre
votre vie si vous le voulez bien votre
nom de jeune fille c'est ivan à zenit
cheikhou zelnik zaini tchèque alors vous
êtes né au début c'est un petit peu
l'histoire de votre ami adriana karembeu
au départ c'est vrai dire il va n'a
aînés dans une ville qui s'appelle
gottwald afin qu'il s'appelait gottwald
of du nom du premier président
communiste de la tchécoslovaquie
gottwald clément gaulle val est donc
maintenant ça a changé de nom s'appelle
l'inma l'époque soit à caudeval duff et
alors c'est une ville industrielle avec
des odeurs de suis comme ça c'est
vraiment lorsqu'il faut dire c'est que
vous aviez une c'est la dictature
communiste et vous avez une vétille et
surveillez votre famille était très
surveillée parce qu'une tante à vous en
48 en 1948 était parti donc
effectivement vous êtes partis vers le
sport est parti vers le ski justement
pour pouvoir voyager parce que sinon y
avait aucun moyen de voyager donc une
vie un peu quand même pas triste mais
une vie pas simple et pas facile en
tchécoslovaquie
vous lancez dans le ski 1 et d'ailleurs
ça vous a beaucoup appris le ski parce
que vous savez a pris la ténacité pas ce
que vous dites quand on descend une
montagne sur deux bouts de bois ben ça
vous apprend à compter que sur vous même
et c'est peut-être ça qui a forgé votre
votre caractère si solide
c'est vrai alors la fin des études
secondaires vous tomber amoureuse d'un
garçon qui était un grand skieur tchèque
qui s'appelle georges siro vodka
inquiets à l'époque étudiant et puis là
vous commencez quand même à faire des
photos de la prague à l'université
charles commencé à faire des photos de
mode dans modhac chose pour moi la chose
la plus importante c'était les
enseignements l'éducation puis après ce
qui est bien sûr pour l'équipe nationale
tchécoslovaque et puisse gagner un petit
peu d'argent à côté comme je pouvais
même dans le monde de la mode en effet
en étant mène une vie difficile veulent
n'y avait pas mais pas le droit de se
teindre les cheveux les patins turier
pas de cinéma arrivait pas discothèque
enfin c'était quand même une vie assez
discuté que ça je peux vous dire il y en
avait plus et alors un jour vous émigré
au canada et vous rejoignez donc votre
fiancée de l'époque qui s'appelait
georges siro vodka comme je les dis et
qui lui a ouvert un magasin de ski au
canada
alors vous allez là-bas bon vous donner
des cours de ski vous trouvez dans une
agence de mannequins à montréal hélas le
fric c'est chic
un jour vous êtes dans une boîte de nuit
à new york avec une amie vous cherchez
une table
vous trouvez pas table que personne ne
vous connaît et le garçon qui vous aide
qui vous aide à trouver une table c'est
donald g
j'ai senti mal sur une épaule puis
j'aime patron science alors j'ai regardé
derrière moi il y avait ce type
absolument superbe et il m'a dit je
m'appelle tonneau tschopp et il m'a dit
vous avez du mal à trouver
alors j'ai regardé j'ai regardé mon ami
je lui ai dit pas on a les bonnes
nouvelles et une mauvaise mais elle m'a
dit c'est quoi la bonne nouvelle c'est
qu'on va voir une table très très vite
parce que ce monsieur là il collait bien
de restaurants la mauvaise nouvelle
c'est que il va venir s'asseoir avec
nous et c'est comme ça que j'ai
rencontrés dans la lys et acier avec
vous et votre ami et en quelques mois
plus tard vous signez votre premier
contrat prénuptial
et après vous êtes mariée avec lui c'est
vrai que vous avez signé un contrat par
an un contrat de mariage par an il y
avait des contrats très rapproché je
comprends pas ça on changeait les
contrats nous n'ont pas tous les ans
peut-être tous les cinq ou six ans on
changeait les contraint c'est beau
l'amour
et alors j'ai vraiment travaillé
beaucoup et se mérite tout ce que j'ai
c'est quelque chose d'immense et tout le
monde croit
ivana est devenu riche après son divorce
avec donald trump est en fait vous
travaillé énormément vous étiez très
impliqué dans les affaires donald frein
vous dirigez un casino à atlantic city
qui était l'un des plus rentables du
monde est dirigé le plaza athénée à new
york a été élu hôtelière de l'année donc
c'est vrai que c'est oui c'est un peu si
c'est un peu énervant toujours de les
gens pensent que vous êtes devenus
riches seulement après votre divorce
alors bon sur notre histoire d'amour
avec donald trump c'est vrai qu'au début
ils avaient des aventures ou fermés un
petit peu les yeux au début vous faites
ce qu'on appelle en france la politique
de l'autruche je sais qu'au moment du
divorce elle a cru que son mari était
fidèle tous les temps à m vous étiez au
courant quand même de l' aventure de
votre mari avec marc lamy
vous étiez au courant je savais pas je
dépanne
je l' ai découvert le soir de noël à
aspen dans un restaurant où on est en
train de skier sur la quête de famille
et quand j'ai appris qu'il avait raison
avec une autre femme et notamment ce que
tu as fais moi même moi j'ai trouvé ça
horrible et quand j'ai découvert les la
liaison j'ai immédiatement demandé liban
sud est un petit peu bourgeoise un petit
peu traditionalistes et pour moi sac à
main tout était cassé vous voyez ça
pouvait pas continuer
on est tous différent massimo lui peut
continuer et recommencer on va commencer
moi pas peut-être que les choses sont
différentes entre les hommes et les
femmes je ne sais pas mais c'est bon je
les proches toujours arriver à un modèle
de trois bourgs joueuses dans sa
mentalité et là des choses très très
stricte
1 alors est ce que c'est vrai ivana
trump à ce que c'est vrai ce qu'on
raconte dans la presse de nous le dire
c'est que vous êtes donc dans ce
restaurant au moment de noël à aspen et
que marla may pulse arrive dans le
restaurant s'approche de vous et vous
dit j'aime votre maillot c'est vrai ça
et à satisfaire
oui oui c'est vrai santa barbara
c'était hélas weiss a esquissé social
exactement ce qui s'est passé si vous
avez appelé également ce même ce à la
veille de noël
en fait tout ça s'est fait en plus
demande mes trois enfants
donc ce n'était pas très agréable et
alors là évidemment vous commencez à
parler divorce eux vous dites je le
laisse partir mais ça va lui coûter cher
alors vous avez un petit peu dit le
problème aussi qu'il ya eu c'est que à
cette époque là ça va aller vite tu l'a
voulu tu vas l'avoir mais j'avais une
question à poser mois mais est ce que
c'est vrai qu'il vous a donné ses
testicules en boucle d'oreille
qu'est ce qu'il va donner ce qu'il m'a
donné
la traductrice est en train de non
seulement des diamants c'est le vendée
diam seulement des diamants mon garçon
alors quatorze 14 millions de 14
millions de dollars
un appartement à new york une maison
amara lago enfin ça va quoi et alors là
après cette histoire vous dites je vais
pas me laisser emporter
vous dites je vais pas me laisser
emporter dans le tourbillon du désespoir
vous décidez de vous battre
c'est que non je vais pas me cacher et
mourir c'est exactement ce qui s'est
passé j'ai une mona la ville c'est
merveilleux je vais pas mais c est mon
ambition c'est qu'ils visitent pas
regarder le passé le passé où il est
fini c'est terminé il faut regarder vers
l'avenir et alors là il ya ça c'est la
première vengeance c'est que vous avez
gagné 10 fois ce qui vous avait donné
lors du lors du divorce mais surtout lui
avec marla michaels il se marie avec
elle et ils divorcent quand même temps
après 13,2 en un an à peu près un ange
qui sont séparés divorcés et la
travailler avec
finalement tout est bien qui finit bien
les spas et l'arrimage pour cette
identité c'est ma femme faisait beaucoup
d'argent 1
on évalue votre fortune je pas si c'est
vrai à 45 millions de dollars vous avez
combien de maisons ivana abbas ait
environ 5 plus le yacht qui s'appelle le
ivan ah oui j'avais signé l'elliott vous
dit
finalement on combien de steak est ce
qu'on peut manger dans une journée alors
quand on est riche on mange combien de
steaks par jour quand on est riche qu'on
vient en revanche de c'est une bonne
chose à dire parce que ya beaucoup de
gens qui sont vraiment option était de
faire de l'argent et encore de l'argent
est toujours largement et moi je connais
beaucoup d'amis qui sont des
millionnaires des billionaire des traits
lyonnais il travaille il faut veiller
que travailler jamais une ambition pour
la famille les enfants c'est simplement
alors combien c'est qu'en effet pour les
manger par dure combien de voitures
ouais combien de maisons maisons il faut
s'arrêter et puis se détendre un petit
peu quand on a on n'a jamais vu un
coffre fort suivre un corbillard alors
serge maintenant j'en ai posé à ivana
trump la question qui tue
alors il va la trempe questions
importantes si demain matin
donald trump revenez vers vous et vous
proposer de reprendre la vie de famille
avec vos enfants
il y en oublie tout on se remet ensemble
tous et on reprend une vie normale tu me
pardonnes excuse moi est ce que vous
seriez d'accord est ce que vous lui
diriez oui ou non au sénat à ce stade je
dirais non
suivant l'accord vise d'abord parce que
je suis amoureuse d'un autre homme
et puis y est tellement de mal qui a été
fait bon bien sûr je suis remonté et
maintenant les enfants ont réussi à
atteindre un stade de paix paisible et
moi je veux continuer avec ma vie et
puis donald a des intérêts qu'ils sont
différents à manger des intérêts
différents je passe beaucoup de temps en
europe
je jouais de ma vie je fais des choses
différentes et lui il continue à
travailler travailler travailler vont
intéresser milliards et c'est pas fait
pour moi ce n'est plus fait pour nos
groupes aucun espoir on allume art
alors dans cette émission comme je
disais tout à l'heure
le public n'est pas seulement là pour
faire ça il peut aussi poser des
questions qui me posais une question
ivana trump vous vous en prie bruce
willis personne tu n'as rien à craindre
mon gars sont une arnaque
le soir il y en a je voudrais savoir
juridiquement aux états unis ce que
c'est plus simple est ce que ça a été
plus simple pour vous de vous marier ou
divorcer en fait se marier très
difficile il suffit d'aller à las vegas
et vous complètement grillé
instantanément savent au couteau d'un 1
10 dollar à peu près par contre un
divorce assez difficile notamment
lorsqu'il ya des intérêts monétaire en
jeu et les hommes
ils sont entrés randin ça c'est typique
des hommes ils sont radins aller en
amérique il ya quand même des lois et
surtout en thelle fourni et à new york
tout ça ça dépend des états américains
normalement la femme épouse qui était
bon ce doit obtenir la moitié des biens
communs mais là on commence à voir un
combat parce que les hommes y à recruter
des avocats et des non non non je veux
pas payer et a pris la télé gaspillage
d'argent un tel gaspillage de temps
finalement ceux qui s'en mettent plein
la poche
ce sont les avocats quelqu'un d'autre
vous venez montpetit la voilà à
ce soir j'aimerais sol et comment
fabienne numéro porte à savoir ivana si
avec donald trump vous avez fait un
mariage d'amour ou un mariage de raison
j'avais construit donald j'avais 28 ans
lui il en avait 30
nous on sait marier par amour ça
d'ailleurs pendant 12 ans et qu'un
mariage absolument superbe
il ya eu deux ans difficiles non non
c'était absolument un mariage d'amour
la branche était pas mal c'était
quelqu'un d'intelligent du moins
j'espère je travaillais beaucoup moins
d'autres fins j'aurais pu trouver
n'importe quel homme que je reviens du
trouver un enjeu les mariés absolument
pas un jour
merci ici est ce que quelqu'un veut
poser une question et de mettre un
compte aux ruelles ou par la non ou oui
venez une jolie robbie van assche qui
s'acquiert et c'est cette french désert
est tarie muller c'est thierry mugler
j'adore il est vraiment lente mais
c'était sa question je crois donc
c'était une question qu'elle est quand
vous avez vous eu yoann yoannn alors
posez votre question ce soir est très
belle sa machine
c'est l'école gardien maxime au fait des
émules
[Applaudissements]
alors ma question était la suivante je
n'ai pas d'appartement
non merci est-ce que d'après votre
expérience
l'argent fait le bonheur je mentirais si
on disait que l'argent il n'a pas
d'importance à l'argent ça vous achetez
des jolies voitures des maisons plus
jolie des vacances plus agréable mais
non ça ne vous achète pas l'amour ça
sera la réponse merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup il a la trempe voilà
le fric c'est chic alors maintenant on
va passer une petite interview il va n'a
très sympathique c'est un petit jeu un
espace sans importance ça s'appelle
l'interview alerte rouge
[Musique]
bien calé ivana trump votre première
pensée quand vous vous trouvez en face
d'un homme séduisant quasiment nul et on
a envie de le tenir dans ses bras
et puis le troisième je vais pas venir
il y avait de l'eau glacée on a envie de
te tenir dans ses bras
ça vous donne une idée peu près mais je
me dis pas la troisième celle qu'elle
est pour vous quel est pour vous il va
mettre un petit salon italien s'est dit
jean dame attention je vais pas dire moi
aussi qu'elle est calé pour vous il va
n'attrape le lieu idéal pour une
étreinte la plage et on sait jamais ce
qui va se passer après olalala
regarde moi
c'est et essayiste bookings sepa et
morgane et c'est toi calabar surtout
avec les italiens sont ces cas là
attention à la attention attention c'est
est ce que vous préférez draguer ou vous
faire draguer c'est toujours l'homme qui
donne droit qui je le sais tout ça c'est
alors de venir à moi c'est ça qui c'est
ça qui leur plaît aux hommes les il aime
travailler pour venir vous chercher
est ce que vous préférez largué vous
faire larguer non non c'est moi qui
l'équipe
ah c'est vous que j'ai dit et ça il faut
vous draguer mais après c'est vous
quitter tous il est passé cet argent si
je dis attention
elle secoue préféré embrasser ou qu on
vous embrasse
j'aime bien les embrasser les hommes on
sanctionne pas ça c'est eux qui m'a
brasse mais j'aime bien passé j'ai chaud
j'ai chaud j'ai changé
l'aspect très blonde hps les blonds l'a
bien alors des problèmes
est-ce que je vais avoir des ennuis
est-ce que no problemo ivana trump est
ce que vous conservez un fantasmes
inavouables of craft bien sûr et je ne
t'ai pas l'admettre mais pas me
confesser est ce que vous croyez que des
fantasmes et ses fantasmes
eh bien il reste à wired et vous souvent
on essaie de lévis vous essayez pas de
vivre tous vos fantasmes quand vous vous
trouvez ça plus sexy de les garder en
vous plutôt que de les vivre
je sais les deux âges essayé les deux
dernières questions ivana trump à coire
connaissez-vous la passion qui s'étale
solution d'abord ça dépend de la
personne
si on parle d'une véritable relation
bien sûr ce sont des signes peut-être un
peu mieux le moment de faire l'amour au
lieu de faire tous les jours qu'on le
fait tous les deux jours où vient ce vol
entre moyen et les noms à tout d'un coup
on vous voyez votre homme qui se teint
les cheveux qui se fait couper les
cheveux qui fait des choses différentes
de ce qui fait d'habitude et il ya des
signes qui font qu'on sait qu'un homme à
une liaison par exemple par exemple il
rentre tard à la maison
bon c'est pas ce qu'il m'est arrivé un
moral vous êtes de bons conseils merci
massive à la trappe
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de dinars
dit tu es abonné vous mettez un pouce
bleus